JEFFREY FREEBURG:
So welcome Chef.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
So my plan was to first
introduce the restaurant which
I have in Sweden, and talk a
little bit about what we do.
And then I was going to go more
deeply into how we work
with vegetables--
how we grow them and
how we store them.
That was my plan.
Maybe I can skip that.
Probably people know
where Sweden is.
But that's where Faviken
is, at least.
You see?
I usually say that it's in the
northern parts of Sweden, but
it's actually in the middle
towards the Norwegian border.
This is what we are.
We're a tiny, tiny restaurant.
We have like 12 to 16 people
dining, 5 nights a week.
It's an ambitious restaurant.
What we try to do up there is
to make the most out the
whatever possibilities we have--
and difficulties as
well, for that matter.
Which manifests foremost
[? bit ?] because we only work
with products from this area.
This area is very interesting
because it has inland climate
where we are.
It's hot in the summer and
very cold winters.
And then if you cross
[? the Scandinavian ?]
mountain range is very
close to us.
Then you get to Norway where
you have coastal climates.
You have a lot of different
things.
A lot of diversity within
a very small region.
And this is a question that
I very often get--
why do you work with products
from a certain area only?
Why don't you work with
products from
all over the world?
And the answer to that
is very simple--
it's actually quality.
Our products-- they are
really, really good.
It's the best products I've ever
worked with anywhere, in
any restaurant.
It's not because they are from
the region as such--
because products don't
get better from--
but yes because they are
from a certain place.
But it gets much better
because we can have
cooperation.
We can have a dialogue with all
the people that produces
our food to the restaurant.
We can give them feedback, and
they can tell us what works
for them, and not.
And we can support each other
which brings progress and
development.
Another question that I get very
often-- why do you have
so few seats?
Why is the restaurant so tiny,
especially now when we are
quite a well-known restaurant.
We could probably fill it many
times over every night.
But that's something that has
never really appealed to me
because I like the format.
I like cooking myself.
I don't like to train a huge
team to do my work.
And also, I like the dining
experience that we can give
people which is a communal
dining experience.
It starts at 7:00.
Everyone arrives at
the same time.
Then we do a little bit
of matchmaking.
We put people together.
They sit together for drinks
for half an hour--
and some appetizers.
And then we move people upstairs
and you have your own
separate tables, like
in any restaurant.
But the difference then is that
everyone will have the
same menu, at the same time,
at the same place.
So everyone will share this
experience, and then be seated
again downstairs in front of
the fireplace afterwards.
So this is our business.
We employ 11 people in total.
7 of them work in the kitchen,
and the rest in front of house
or with the hotel
which we have.
It's a 6 room hotel, so
it's also very small.
One of my chefs is responsible
for all produce--
he more or less does
only that.
Because it takes a lot of work
to get all the stuff into the
restaurant.
Not only to get the quality,
but actually to
get enough of it.
Because even if the restaurant
is tiny, we serve about 3,000
people a year, and everyone
will have in
between 20 or 25 servings.
So it makes up slightly over
60,000 plates a year-- which
is quite a lot, acutally.
The number of how the work hours
in the restaurant is
split between the different
things we do, is also very
different from other
restaurants.
Because in most other
restaurants people will work
with cooking only.
They would be like 90% cooking
and 10% cleaning.
But with us it's 50% working
with the produce before the
cooking starts, which is a lot
of work hours and a lot of
money for us-- it's
a tiny business.
And this is mainly spent on
getting the produce in.
Driving around, talking to
people, developing our
relations with the community,
and getting all the
produce to the farm.
And also working in the storage
techniques which I'm
going to talk later about.
So that was a little bit about
the restaurant and such.
This is how we work the
vegetable year at Faviken.
So if you start from
the bottom, you
see two blue lines.
And they show when in the year
we use a lot of forage
vegetables because this is
something that people always
put together with restaurants
from my area.
There's always big focus on
forage, right now-- which not
always the case.
It's just during a few, few
brief moments in a year.
So you see that in May and
June-- that's the only, really
where we actually work with
the foraged vegetables and
foraged herbs.
Just for 6 weeks maximum when
they are young and tender in
the spring.
And then during midsummer we
don't really do that anymore
because they're not
delicious anymore.
And there's really no need
because there's so much other
things as well, going on.
And then the forage stuff-- it
comes back again in August,
and then it's not herbs and
vegetables anymore.
Then there's mushrooms
and berries, mainly.
And it continues all through
autumn and finishes in early
winter-- which is, more
or less, now.
The red line--
it marks the time when we
actually have fresh vegetables
from the garden like most
restaurants would have every
day of the year, nowadays
because you transport things
all around the place.
For us it's quite brief.
We try to make the most out of
that time, so during that time
in the summer, everything is
about showing the produce in
their [? huest, ?]
freshest form.
So you can have a chef running
down to the vegetable garden
picking some peas, and more or
less popping the pod straight
on the plate and serving them.
Well then in the winter--
if you look at the green line
which shows the time of year
where we have to use things that
are stored or prepared in
a way to keep--
it's all about something else.
Because all those storing
techniques-- no matter which
you choose to use--
they will do something
to the product.
It will make them less
of a product.
The carrot will be less of a
carrot because it's stored.
It will be different.
And that's something that
we try to embrace and to
incorporate into the cooking
during the winter.
So it gives a very special
flavor and a very special
character to everything
we do--
a large part of the year.
This is about one kilometer
from the restaurant.
And this is quite typical--
how the grounds would look like
where we would forage in
the spring and early summer.
So you see there's in the
valley you would have
coniferous forest.
And then quite quickly as the
elevation goes up, it thins
out and you have more of this
low shrubs, and a lot lichens.
This is a little list of the
different wild vegetables that
we often use in the
restaurant.
And I'm not going to go through
all of these because
there's so many.
But if someone would have a
special interest in this, you
can email the restaurant and
I'll send it back to you.
The vegetable gardens.
This is something that I'm
very, very proud of.
It was the first year--
which is now five years ago
that I work at Faviken--
I started a little
vegetable plot.
And it was just like 20 square
meters or something like that.
And I grew some onions, some
carrots, some beets, a few
sweet peas for the summer,
and a few more things.
And I realized that it's the
ultimate way of seeing to you
that you have the best
possible vegetables
available to you.
Because you can influence so
many things just by choosing
different growing techniques
and different varieties of
vegetables.
A carrot is not just
a carrot--
there's like hundreds
of varieties.
And within those varieties you
can also affect the end result
so much by when you harvest
them or how you grow them.
Two different photos from
the same place.
One is in early spring when
everything is on its way up.
And then one is about this time
of year, when the first
snow has arrived.
This is how it would look
like in the summer.
This is probably around
July last year.
This is how the vegetable
gardens are laid out.
They're much larger now,
than when I started.
They grow a little
bit every year--
become larger and larger.
And that's mainly because,
for me, gardening
is a work in progress.
It's a learning process--
the whole thing.
Because there's so many
things to try to
understand and to learn.
So we just add on.
As soon as I find something
interesting, we
add on a new section.
And at this point, we have--
if you look to the left
a little [INAUDIBLE]
there's something where it's
labeled, "four part crop
rotation," which is four raised
beds in which we grow
four different kinds of plants
that take different nutrients
out of the soil to grow,
and that has different
sensitivities for viruses
and other dangerous
microorganisms.
And we rotate them every year
to prevent buildup of those
microorganisms, and to prevent
depletion of soil nutrients.
This is how that one looks.
It's quite straightforward.
This is like any home garden
actually, this one.
The white stuff on top-- that's
just to prevent the
young seedlings from frost
in the summer.
We take those off in mid-June.
In the middle we have a
different system which is
labeled the "six part crop
rotation," which raised
uncovered beds.
And that also has strict
irrigation.
And this is a more intense
way of farming the land.
It gives us the possibility to
raise the soil temperature.
Because see that black stuff?
It's a black cloth which
we cover the soil in.
And first it prevents moisture
to evaporate, but also it
raises the soil temperature.
So we are basically--
instead of having a subarctic
climate-- we are somewhere
like in the south of Sweden or
Denmark, where it has a much
more temperate climate.
So here, every crop grows from
its own little hole.
Which it's a lot of work
to do this in spring--
to actually plant everything
and to set it up.
But then it's very good, because
you don't have to
spend a lot of time
cleaning out weeds
and things like that.
But this we've seen.
We followed this.
Now we've done this for three
years, and we followed it and
we see that we actually are not
able to put back all the
nutrients in the soil again
that we take out.
Because this is so intense, it
really produces a lot of
vegetables.
And because we don't use heavy
machinery, it's all turned by
hand and it's all transported
by hand.
We have a hard time putting back
all the organic nutrients
in the soil again which sooner
or later we're going to have
to change this practice
and do something else.
And then we have my favorite--
down on the right part--
which is in between
those ones.
It's a three part
crop rotation.
30% of it is grown with
leguminous plants which are
not harvested, but instead
plowed down in
the soil every autumn.
Leguminous plants-- they have
bacteria growing on the roots
which has the ability to fix
nitrogen from the atmosphere.
And you turn that down every
autumn, and let it rot into
the soil, and that's giving
back organic nutrients.
And this one is not covered
with [? claw fighter. ?]
It's covered with grass
clippings which serves the
same purpose, but it's much
nicer in [INAUDIBLE],
The herb gardens
look like that.
The red building is
the restaurant.
Kitchen would be in the middle,
and then the higher
part, in the back-- that's where
the dining room is on
the second floor.
The herb garden is where we
produce all the fresh flowers
and herbs for the summer, but
also everything that we dry
and store for the winter, in
terms of seasoning and herbs.
And this is the choice that one
has to do every time, when
one decides to store
a vegetable.
Because there's basically
two different schools of
techniques.
Either you utilize some kind of
mechanism already present
in the plant that makes it
keep for a long time.
Or you kill the plant off and
everything within the
restricted atmosphere
around the plant.
The technique that kill the
plant-- they kill all the
harmful bacteria--
as I said-- in the restricted
atmosphere.
And that can be for example,
that you take a carrot and you
put it in the jar.
You fill the jar with some brine
or water or something,
and then heat-treat the jar.
You bring it to 90 degrees And
keep it at 90 degrees for at
least 10 minutes.
And that will kill or disable
almost all microorganisms
within that jar.
And it can be other examples
like for example pickles--
also a killing technique.
The non-killing ones that are
interesting, in the way that
they use mechanisms already
present in the plant.
And that is for example, all
root vegetables that we use
like carrots, and beets,
and things like that.
They are biannuals.
Basically their life cycle is
that the first year, they will
sprout from a seed and
they will grow.
During summer they will collect
a lot of energy
through photosynthesis and store
this as chemical energy
in the root, in the form
of carbohydrates--
and that's the energy
we consume.
That's what we want to
use in the vegetable.
Basically it does this just
because it wants to get ahead
in the race of life.
Because next spring, when it's
dormant during one winter, it
will be able to sprout
a flower before all
the one-year herbs.
[? See this ?] doesn't have to
wait for the photosynthesis to
really get going in spring.
It can just go straightaway--
consume the energy it
has in the root.
And this is something we can
use if we just harvest the
plant at the right time, when
it's set on hibernation, when
it decided to go hibernate
for winter.
We can harvest it and we can
store it in an environment
which is similar to the
temperature and the humidity
and the soil-- it can
be a root cell or
something like that.
And this is something that
I find very interesting.
And this took me while to
actually figure out--
that all the methods to prolong
the shelf life or to
store vegetable-- it never
makes them better.
It just makes them different.
And as I said before, a carrot
is never better as a carrot
than when it was just taken
out of the soil and eaten.
But everything you do with that
carrot after you pick it
and take the first bite--
it will make
it less of a carrot--
which is not always a bad
thing, but it's a fact.
So here's a few specific
techniques.
So this is how we can keep for
example, broccoli, kale, and
cabbage, in a winter garden.
Because many of the
brassicas--
they produce different
agents in them that
keep them from freezing.
They contain a lot of sugars,
and sometimes even a little
bit of alcohol.
And they keep on metabolizing.
Even though they are frozen,
they keep on
metabolizing just a bit.
So it's very fascinating because
if you take a broccoli
like that, that you left in the
garden, on the plant, that
has been frozen for like 1 and
1/2 months, and harvest it,
and you take into your kitchen,
it's still a fresh
broccoli when it defrosts.
But if you take same broccoli
and you freeze it for one and
a half months, and you defrost
it in the kitchen, then it's a
frozen broccoli.
I find that very fascinating.
And we just leave all those
brassicas in the garden and we
keep on harvesting them until
they run out or until the
moose eat them all.
Clamping.
So this is a way of using that
mechanism that I talk about
earlier-- the biennal thing--
and this is probably the first
way that we humans stored
vegetables in any efficient
manner.
And basically what to do is
that you harvest all your
roots, you bring them close to
your house, you make these few
trenches, and then you put
some straw between the
trenches, you put all the root
vegetable there, cover it with
more straw to insulate it, and
then you cover it with soil.
And this will keep a very, very
steady temperature over
winter because those vegetables
that are set on
hibernation-- they're not
dead, they're still
metabolizing.
So they actually consume a
little bit of energy and
produce a little bit of heat.
So they will keep in there from
freezing-- even in our
subarctic climates--
and also the humidity,
because it's placed
straight on the soil.
It will keep very, very steady
and level all through winter--
which is important when
you store vegetables.
The only problem with this
is that you can't
really just take one.
You have to take them all out of
there when you break it in
the winter which can be
slightly impractical.
And that's why you have the root
cellar-- which is in my
opinion, one of the best ways
of storing vegetables.
It works with the
same principle.
You keep a very steady and
level temperature.
It's dark.
And you have the same humidity
as the plant would experience
in its growing environment.
Inside the root cellar we
would store our root
vegetables like this--
buried in sand.
The sand helps preventing
fluctuations in temperature
and humidity even more.
So you get an even more level
climate for the vegetables.
Other things which
are not roots--
like for example, cabbage--
they are strictly not speaking
biannuals, but they have some
of those functions anyway
because it's just about
surviving for them.
Because if they would not flower
the first time or they
would be able to-- under
certain circumstances--
survive until next summer, and
continue the life then.
That's something we
also can use.
So we can harvest the cabbage
when it's ripe.
We can put it in the cellar
and leave it for that.
After about 6 or 8 weeks it
will dry and look like
parchment paper on
the outside.
It would be like
a little skin.
Then after--
I would say--
2 more months, it's all moldy.
Looks horrible.
And it looks like something
[? it ?]
[? was ?] throw out of your
fridge straightaway if you
found it there.
But the fact is that if you just
take that skin off, there
would still be a fresh and
healthy cabbage on the inside
because it's layered.
And those layers-- they protect
the layer underneath
from damage from bacteria.
Because the bacteria have
to travel around
each bend in layers.
So it's a very long way
to go for them.
And if you keep them all through
winter, new little
tiny cabbages will start
sprouting from the root stalk.
Oh, yeah the leek machine.
I read a report from the
Swedish University of
Agriculture a few years ago
which basically said that you
can store leeks for up to 290
days if you had the perfect
surrounding.
Like the perfect environment
for them.
And that was 90% humidity
and 0.1 degrees.
You can store them for 290 days
without significant loss
of quality--
which is very interesting
to me.
You have the very, very high
humidity to keep them from
drying out.
And you have the very low
temperature to slow down their
metabolism so they don't really
change that much.
So what I did was that I bought
the domestic freezer
and I tampered with the
thermostat so it keeps 0.1 to
0.3 degrees Celsius.
And I filled it with a little
bit of sand, and I harvested
all the leeks and then
replanted them
in the sand, again.
And then I left it all
through winter.
And this [? has ?]
[? stood ?] there so long so
that all the other people
working on the estate-- they
just saw it as sort of a
permanent installation
there in the corner.
So it's covered.
When we used the leeks in the
spring this is how it looked.
It was covered in all
kinds of crap.
Onions and garlic.
They can be dried.
Most times when you buy onions
and garlic, the leaves have
been cut when they were still
green, and then you can never
store them for more than
maybe two months.
Because as soon as you cut them
there, you will have an
entryway for mold, spores,
and bacteria.
But if you leave them--
like those garlic lying out--
exposed to UV radiation,
they will die.
And they will seal themselves
off, and they will wait for
next summer.
So then when these are dry,
then you can cut them.
You can store for a very long
time in a dry and cool
environment.
Basically you can store
them for two years.
Pasteurizing is one of those
techniques that will kill the
plant and also everything else
in the surrounding area.
These tomatoes--
they are pasteurized in brine.
It's a technique that were
very, very common in
households just until 50 or 60
years ago, and then people
stopped because it was
so easier to buy.
People started having domestic
basis freezers and things
[INAUDIBLE] so it was much
easier to buy the produce from
a supermarket.
But it's a very good
technique.
It'll produce an excellent
result.
It can be a little bit dangerous
because of the
bacteria that can survive in
there which are [INAUDIBLE]
botulinum, which gives botulism,
which will result in
you being dead if
you eat them.
But it can be avoided very
easily by respecting a few
very simple rules.
And one is that you can either
keep the pH level under 3.84
because then they cannot grow.
And that can be done by adding
something acidic.
You can keep the tempter under
four degrees at all times
after the cooking.
And that will keep them
from growing as well.
Or if you're uncertain that you
have been able to do those
two factors, you can also
heat the product
before eating it again.
You can heat it to 80 degrees
and keep it there for five
minutes, and that will destroy
all toxins as well.
Pickling in vinegar--
It's a very, very safe method
of preservation.
And it works by lowering the pH
level by adding some kind
of chemical agent-- for example
vinegar or lemon juice
or whatever.
Very few bacteria can grow in
a sour or acid environment.
Pickling by lactobacillus
fermentation--
it works sort of in the same
way, but instead of adding a
chemical, you try to make the
lactobacilllus already
present, thrive.
And that's usually done by
adding salt which suppresses
other bacterial activity which
gives the lactobacillus an
unfair advantage.
And then they start growing.
And then by consuming
carbohydrates they also
produce lactic acid which lowers
the pH level under 3.94
in quite a short
period of time.
And this can also be a little
bit risky because if it takes
too long, you can have the
same problem as with the
pasteurized foods--
that you have other bacteria
growing as well.
And that will probably be
e.coli or [INAUDIBLE]
which are not good--
any of them.
And drying herbs and mushrooms
is something we do
quite a lot as well.
What's important when you're
drying is to dry very, very
quickly, and in a cool
temperature.
Because if you dry them in an
oven, they taste like hay, or
they all taste the same,
no matter what you do.
If you dry them in room
temperature in your room, they
decay so much from enzymatic
breakdown.
So you kind of transform
the flavor a lot.
Like if you're drying mushrooms
at room temperature
for a week, they taste
like soy, almost.
If you do it with herbs, they
lose all the green color and
all those fresh aromas.
So we use one of of these which
is an industrial grade
dehydrator.
It takes about 15 liters
of water away from the
atmosphere per hour.
We keep it in a room, which
is more or less airtight.
It enables us to dry out about
10 kilos of herbs in more or
less two hours at 18 degrees
Celsius which preserves all
the very, very fragile aromas
and all the beautiful color.
Using antibacterial properties
naturally present in plants is
an interesting way of
working that we
haven't used that much.
And on the photo you have
some lignon berries.
Lignon berries are naturally
very high in benzoic acid
which is something that the
food industry would add to
food to prevent mold
from growing.
And basically what you can
do is you can take lignon
berries, put them in a jar,
cover them with water, and
then keep them for years.
They never go bad, and they
change very little in texture
and flavor as well, which
is interesting.
You can also put things
in there.
You can put half a cabbage in
the box with lignon berries.
And it will also keep for two
years without much happening
with it except that is pink
in the end, obviously.
Leguminous plants--
something that we use a lot.
It's very versatile.
You can use them from the first
little sprout in spring
in a salad to peas and beans
in the summer, and then all
the way to using the mature
crop-- which has been dried,
[? trashed ?]
and stored for a long time.
Or as here-- ferment them,
like you do with miso for
example, in many Asian
countries.
Basically what we do is we have
a dried brown bean or pea
which is steamed for a long
time to kill any other
bacteria or mold
growing on it.
And then we infect it with a
particular mode which is
called aspergillus oryzae
which, when it grows it
produces an enzyme that breaks
down protein into glutamic
acid which is very savory
and delicious.
So that will be like
miso in the end.
But not with soybeans but
with other beans.
That was it.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: All right.
Thank you.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Thank you.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: Definitely
the most unique
chef we've had here.
No, seriously.
But how did you get started
with this process?
I mean when you opened your
restaurant did you have all
these things in place or--
MAGNUS NILSSON: No, no.
Definitely not.
not.
But many of them--
I saw them being used when I
grew up in this area which has
been very good at keeping
its old traditions.
And I never learned them back
then, but I saw them, and I
got interested in them, and
started learning about them.
Started implementing them
in our environment.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: Yeah, so is
your restaurant pretty much
100% sustainable?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Depends on how
you see it. our customers are
not because most of our
customers are flying from all
over the world.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: OK, that's
a good answer.
So I ask every chef that comes
to Google this question--
what do you think the kitchen
of the future is going to be
like in let's say, 50 years?
Are we going to be only
cooking on electric--
or what do you think?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Well I already
cook on electric, actually.
But I think that's obviously
impossible to answer.
And I think you can only say
what you hope for it to be.
And I hope for it to be much
more diverse than it is today.
I hope for people to look
more within what they
have in their area.
To be more focused on what
possibilities and difficulties
they have, and what really
interests them, rather than
looking on what everyone
else is doing.
Because that's something that's
very common today.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: Yeah,
good answer.
So I heard that you actually
didn't want to start a
restaurant before you started
this-- is that correct?
MAGNUS NILSSON: For a while
I stopped cooking-- yeah.
And I studied wine.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: So why
did you decide to
go back and do this?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Basically I
lived in France for a while,
and then I moved back to Sweden,
and I stopped cooking
because it was not
so pleasant.
Everything looked like what
my [INAUDIBLE] in
Boston, but less good.
Because I was less good than
him, and the produce I had at
hand was much less good than
what he had in France.
So that's why I stopped
cooking and I
started studying wine.
Because my idea was to
become a wine writer.
And after finishing that I was
offered a 3 month job at
Faviken, working with the family
who owns the estate to
more or less work with
the wine cellar.
And buy some wine, teach them
how to administer the wine
cellar, and then go on.
And then I stayed.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: So I heard
that you wrote the book in a
very short amount of time--
4 months--
how was that?
MAGNUS NILSSON: I started a
little bit earlier, but then
it was very interesting.
I had a lot of things that I
wanted to say, apparently.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: Yeah, it's a
beautiful book, by the way.
All right, well, I want to
open it up to Googler
questions so please, if
you have a question,
step up to the mic.
Don't all rush at the
same time, please.
MAGNUS NILSSON: All 15 of you.
AUDIENCE: So since you're
a wine guy--
I mean, wine and beer
are essentially
ways of also storing--
MAGNUS NILSSON: Definitely.
AUDIENCE: --foods.
So do you have plans of going
in that direction as well?
MAGNUS NILSSON: It's funny
you're asking because I
actually just brought a brewery
like two months ago.
And it's being dismantled right
now, and it's going to
be shipped to Faviken.
And this winter we're going
to learn how to use it.
And then next year, we--
I already ordered the barley
that we're going
to plant and grow.
Hopefully it's going
to be a very
interesting learning process.
AUDIENCE: So you're very focused
on cooking locally and
eating locally.
But what is it about the area
around Faviken that you find
most exciting?
MAGNUS NILSSON: I don't know.
I think I find it exciting
because I grew up there.
I spent a large part of my life
there, and I thought I
knew everything about it.
And then when I got back after
being away a while, and
started working there, and
started working this way, I
realized that I knew very
little about this area.
And there's still so much left
to understand and to discover
and to learn about--
which is fascinating.
AUDIENCE: So you told us a lot
about vegetables, but so
what's your approach
to fish and meats?
MAGNUS NILSSON: So that's
like two more talks.
But I can do it very,
very briefly.
With fish--
all the fish that we work
with-- it comes
from the same company.
It's family owned, and it's on
the coastline in Norway about
2 hours from the restaurant.
All the fish is cough
on hook and line.
And we work with species that
are red-listed which is
slightly controversial today in
restaurants Because I think
that the problem is not the fact
that there's very little
of some fish.
The problem is the way
that they are fished.
And I like to support this
company which fishes in a way
that if everyone fished like
them, we would have very
little of the problems
we have at the
world's fish docks today.
So we work with them.
And then we work with a few
small fishery businesses in
the area, as well as supply
freshwater fish.
For meat--
all the meat comes from
people we know.
There are a few farms that
we work with in the area.
And we have sheeps
on the estate.
And I also live on a
farm where I have
sheeps, poultry and bees.
So some of the stuff comes
from there as well.
And what's different in the way
that we work with meat is
that the only buy
whole animals.
And you buy them when
they're alive.
We pay the farmer--
when he has something he calls
me, and we go there--
either me or someone else
from the kitchen.
We look at the animal, and then
we decide if we're going
to buy it or not.
But if we buy it, we buy
it there and then.
And that's about six months
before it goes to the
slaughterhouse.
And then we pay them a premium
to take care of the animal in
a way that we like in the end.
And then we take it to
the slaughterhouse.
And we take care of that whole
logistical process to secure
the quality that we want.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: So I love
your whole approach.
What does your restaurant
look like in a year?
Are you going to be doing
more covers--
MAGNUS NILSSON: No, it's going
to be the same but it's going
to be much better.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: And how is
it going to be better?
MAGNUS NILSSON: We've developed
during the last two
or three years we've developed
a system which we work within
which I'm finally quite
happy with.
The format and logistical
system surrounding the
restaurant, the way we
work with produce,
and all that stuff.
And now the really fun
part has just begun.
And that's when we start to
develop within this system.
So that's going to be
a very interesting.
There's so much to do yet.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: Yeah,
very impressive.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any favorite
restaurants in San Francisco?
I've never been to
San Francisco.
I came like midday today,
and I'm going
into the city tonight.
But I'm going to cook at Qua
the day after tomorrow.
Which is going to be
very interesting.
I've never been to California
before.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: Well you
came in a good week.
So what are some of
your favorite
restaurants in America?
Do you have any?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Oh, that's
so difficult to answer.
There are so many good
restaurants and they are so
different from each other.
So I don't think I have
a good answer there.
AUDIENCE: Seems like you really
pride yourself on being
different--
and you said, strange--
and not really looking out
at other people and
what they're doing.
So what is your creative
process like?
And where do you get you're
new ideas from?
MAGNUS NILSSON: I think that the
most important thing when
you're working any professional
craft where
there's an amount of creativity
involved is to
master your skills.
Like to really, really
understand and master your
techniques that you use.
Because that enables you to be--
at least enables me-- to
be intuitive.
And that's how I work.
The creative process
is very intuitive.
And then I might get interested
in the subject and
I just go all in for that and I
contact all the people that
know the most about
this subject.
And I start researching it
myself, and I start working
with it and trying
to understand it.
But that's not for me,
the creative part.
That's just creating the tool
or producing the tool to be
creative in the end.
That was a very strange
answer, but anyhow.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: So how hard
is it to get into your
restaurant?
MAGNUS NILSSON: We take
reservations 90 days ahead at
the maximum.
So if you want to come to
the restaurant just
[? hang on lock ?] when the
reservations open, and there
shouldn't be much
of a problem.
JEFFREY FREEBURG: OK.
All right, great.
Any more questions?
OK, he'll be up here to sign
the books if anyone wants
their cookbook signed.
So, thank you very much.
Thanks for coming.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah, thanks
for having me here.